what is going on everybody welcome to
part 26 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part in the next few
videos we're going to be talking about
is base map and what base map is is it's
a way for us to plot geographically
using matplotlib and typical matplotlib
syntax so what we need first is to
actually acquire base map and so in
order to do that what you want to do is
head to matplotlib org slash base map
and that'll take you here so it's kind
of like an extension in matplotlib but
you just you don't have it by default so
once you come here go ahead and go to
the download and then you'll want to
head to the windows installers here and
basically the source code to is here and
click on the latest version now the
problem with this is they do have
executables for Windows users but the
last executables for python 3.3 I'm
using 3.4 and actually 3.5 is available
so they're clearly not getting updated
for whatever reason but the source code
is here so you can click on this and
then download the source I don't need
the source because I've already
downloaded it but that's how you would
get it from there what you would need is
something like seven zips so 7-zip is
like seven - zip I'll just bring up an
example of that really quick yeah so
head - like 7-zip org if you don't have
7-zip to install this way and then I
install or I'm all my files download -
you know my username and then downloads
so then what you can do is you can open
up a command window to that location so
mine would be downloads and see I'm
trying to make my font a little bigger
for every one that'll do yeah so in the
downloads I have that base map 1.0 0.7
so if I wanted to download that well
first we have to actually extract that
so I've got two versions of it here you
were first will pay attention to this
one because this is what we just
downloaded the other is a wheel we'll
get to that so to use to download via
this option you can right click 7-zip
extract here it'll take a moment and it
extracts into this distribution folder
then you get this base map tar file
again 7-zip extract here that'll be fine
and you
get this folder in here you have a set
up dot pi so let's go back one file into
here hold down shift right click open
command window here and now we're in it
and we use that set up PI so what we
will do is either Python setup PI
install but it might say pythons not a
not found so what you could do is you
might if that happens you can go see
colon slash Python 34 and then Python
setup PI install now it still might be
the case this doesn't work out for you
so the next way you can install base map
is using the wheel file and so to get
there let me find the link here if I
forget someone remind me and I'll post
the link in the description of this
video and that is this website here this
is just the unofficial binaries for a
bunch of Python modules and what we're
looking for is base maps so we can just
ctrl F base map there it is click it
come down here and then choose your
version so I'm on three point four and
so I want three four and then I have an
AMD 64 because I'm on 64-bit version of
Python now a lot of people confuse their
operating system with their version of
Python you can have a 64-bit operating
system but you still probably have
32-bit Python the only time you have
64-bit python is if you purposely tried
to download 64-bit python to find out
you can just type in either python or
the full path to python like this and
then read the very top I have 64-bit it
literally says 64-bit if you're says
32-bit you have 32-bit anyway download
the one that's applicable to you so
either it'll be probably if you're using
3.4 it would be either this one or this
one download that once you have that
downloaded we head back to our my
downloads directory that will give you
this dot wheel file now what you would
do is we want to open up a command
window here so I'm going to right click
with holding shift right click downloads
open command window here and then again
you would do the same thing as before
you would watch the not the same thing
but C colon slash Python 34 scripts
you might get away with just saying pip
but I don't I've multiple versions of
Python so pip install and then we want
to make sure we get the wheel so base
map
that's the tar.gz this is the wheel you
hit enter there it would unpack the
wheel install the wheel and all this
kind of fun fancy stuff at the end of
all of this what you should be able to
do is open a Python script I'm going to
move all this out of the way now
open up a Python script and do the
following you should be able to say from
MPL underscore toolkits dot base map
import capital b base map so let's save
and run that make sure that works and as
long as you don't get an error here that
worked so let's go ahead and show like a
really quick basic example of bringing
up a map so we're going to go import
matplotlib pipe lot as PLT and then
we're going to say is m for our map
equals base map and then in here well
you might not I think we need a
projection let's try it without a
projection though well let's keep going
then and then let's say PLT show see if
we get a map not we don't get it mapped
so we'll have we have to specify
projection here this is the only thing
that should be required to a base map so
projection equals and this is mil this
is short for a Miller projection we'll
talk a little bit about those in a
second but let's first bring this up
okay so what the projection gives us is
basically this is just the Miller
projection but we actually we have to
still draw like a few things to this
graph to make anything kind of pop up so
we'll say is m dot draw coastlines and
let's try it with just draw coastlines
them in that case there we go so now we
actually have something on our graph and
this is just a it's a Miller projection
like I said well we'll talk about that
in just a moment but now we've got the
graph we've got clearly this is a map
and we've got you know our continents
and stuff on here
so with draw coastlines we could add
some other stuff like m dot fill
continents so this will change the
contents to be like a different
then like the rest of the stuff so let's
just run that real quick so this is the
default color but you can pass other
colors in here to color them pretty much
whatever you want I just want to show
that quick example now let's head to
matplotlib org slash base map wait for
that to load it's taking a while some
reason map plot live I think I mentioned
this earlier like a lot of times it just
doesn't load for me or it'll take a long
time but there are a bunch of projection
options with matplotlib because
depending on like what your goals are
with graphs or with like Geographic
graphs and maps you might have different
things because you have to understand
the the world is a sphere but most maps
are like a flat 2d square right and the
world is not a flat 2d square like if
you went and bought like a big poster
that was a map and you bought like a big
I don't know exercise ball and you tried
to like wrap that poster around the
exercise ball yeah it would result
pretty poorly in a globe right because
it's distorted whenever you have
something up on like a - when you have a
sphere that's represented in a 2d kind
of square representation so something's
always distorted usually what's going to
happen is either there's distortion from
the left to the right or most common
up-and-down distortions so the stuff at
the top or the bottom is more distorted
so let's close out of this and look at
base map here let's click on the
introduction let's get to I'm looking
for our setting up the map there we go
so these are all the possible
projections so the one that we're using
is Miller but there's a bunch like we
can just kind of click a bunch of these
just to kind of get an idea of a bunch
of the just click a few random ones here
ok so this is one this is the one we're
using so that's Miller and then you've
got stuff that it's like you know to
show like if you were really looking to
show like just this stuff up here like
this specific area this is also you can
read like the descriptions of azimuthal
like up here as far as like what the
point of that one is but then you've got
this and so yeah this would be like as
you know the earth from a satellite and
like you can use this and
you can actually specify like how far
that satellite would be and you can kind
of zoom in or out on the earth that's
another example here's another one where
clearly this is quite distorted and
you've got like stuff like this where
there's a little less distortion going
on but clearly it's still slightly
distorted and and so on so there's a lot
of different ways that we can go about
visualizing the world basically we'll
just kind of stick with this Miller
projection but just know that these
other projections exist you can do all
kinds of different projections but we'll
stick with the Miller one so anyways uh
that's it for this tutorial the next
tutorial will kind of start talking
about the options that are available to
us with base map and all that if you
have any questions or comments up to
this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time